الحديث عن الجواسيس الروس في اوكرانيا
يفتح الباب امام ملف اوسع وهو الجواسيس
الروس النائمون الذين تحدثت عنهم الصحيفه
تايمز البريطانيه وقالت انها شبكه تنكشف
شيئا فشيئا في اوروبا تناولت التقرير
كيفيه تخفيهم وسرد قصص مع بعضهم الى جانب
السبب في زياده النشاط الغربي في التعرف
عليهم حاليا من قصص هؤلاء الجواسيس اورد
التقرير ان شابا البرازيليا يدعى دكتور
مولر فيريرا حاصل على درجات الماجستير من
احدى جامعات امريكا وصل الى مطار شيفرول
بامستردام في ايبل الجاري لتلقي تدريب
داخلي في المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في
لهايه لكن الامور لم تسر وفقا لما خطط له
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكي كان
ابلغ السلطات الهولنديه ان هذا الشاب ليس
برازيليا بل هو ضابط في المخابرات
العسكريه الروسيه واسمه
بعد ذلك تمت اعادته الى ساو باولو حيث حكم
عليه بالسجن 15 عاما بتهمه انتحال الهويه
كما اورد التقرير قصه الروسي ميخائيل
ميكوتشين الذي يخضع للاستجواب في النرويج
منذ اكتوبر الماضي بتهمه كونه ضابطا في
المخابرات العسكريه الروسيه ويتنكروا في
شخصيه امريكي جنوبي